okay
you guys obviously google had a little
bit of an outage yesterday right 30
minutes to an hour was out
google and youtube and apparently amazon
had it as well the week prior to that
uh what are your thoughts about a
company this big having an outage a
google
having an outage for 30 minutes do you
have an opinion on that i do i think
it's unacceptable
i mean i i cannot believe i mean when
you think one thing about these tech
companies is they don't have outages
i mean that's something that your local
i you know your local internet provider
has you know your cable company goes
down for a little bit or something like
that
not google and it makes me just think
you know this is becoming a little bit
more didn't youtube have something a few
weeks ago as well
and and i bring it back to the fact that
these tech companies are so quick
to have everybody work from home no one
has to come back to the office
uh i believe that there's got to be some
sort of
correlation between the fact that they
don't have the engineers in-house
they don't have everybody you know under
the same roof and you're having these
issues
i mean when you look at these corporate
campuses for these tech companies it's
staggering how big they are
i mean we're talking about what 45 acres
for one of them yeah you know millions
literally millions of square feet of
office space and then you think what
apple okay so apple just has that
circular new thing it's like four
stories tall
seven million square feet of office
space and it cost them a little bit over
a billion
and you're thinking that's nothing to
these companies so they
there must be something about them not
wanting to have
everybody in the office there must be
some huge savings because
you know what's a billion bucks to them
that's nothing you know that's security
for
sergey brin for one year probably or
something like that you know it really
is minimal
in the grand scheme but i really think
and they're so quick to say hey you
don't have to come back to work until
the middle of 2021 or
twitter's saying you don't ever have to
come back to the office how is that a
good thing
you know the guy who is the exception to
that is reed hastings he says there's
nothing positive
about us not being in the office
together i want them all back as soon as
possible
his alternative is four days at the
office one day flex where maybe you work
at home which i think that makes a
little bit more sense
you've people are gonna start going nuts
if they're just gonna be working from
home forever i know so many people
trapped working at home in l.a in
california they feel different to me
i think they're going a little stir
crazy it's crazy you're not as active
you don't have the social interaction
it's a very negative thing for the
country
uh a couple things uh i don't know what
happened with the how long was the
shutdown a half hour
yeah i think it was 30 minutes 30
minutes first thing that came to mind
maybe because i was reading that
treasury story is
hackers you know modern day warfare
are aren't going to be hot wars aren't
going to be
you know that's why i think you know not
to get all political like the whole
building the wall thing is so
archaic like today it's you know
um bio warfare hacking
software viruses what have you so
who hacked something is is where i'm
going i think so
you know what it also you know the song
i'm only human
you know that song they did in in this
auto insurance commercial i don't know
if you've seen it
yet yeah yeah the guy keeps hitting
stuff and you know
mistakes yeah it's a great auto
insurance company
who is that no it's not like human
league yeah so i'm only human
born to make mistakes right so is google
allowed to make mistakes i mean that's
the part can you imagine like google's
down we're furious
i cannot believe this free service is
down what is wrong with you guys you
guys better get it back
up it's free damn it you know we ain't
paying for it right it's not a
you think that's a human mistake all of
the internet
all i'm saying is what google does is
it gives smaller business owners the
ability to realize that even a
juggernaut like a google makes mistakes
right
even a juggernaut like google can make
mistakes like that but i do like what
you said about the fact that when people
are now working from an office maybe
they're not as
focused as they would have been working
from home
[Music]
you